Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason
how's it going fresh I was gonna do a
video where I draw a fanfiction we've
done this before
I did one it was John Cena and the guy
and I'm like this is awesome but I just
feel like there needs to be more like
I'm not satisfied just with this picture
so we're gonna take this to the next
level it's gonna make it a little creepy
but yeah who's stopping me so what we
firs needs to do I need to find two boys
kissing Oh God not boys two men men two
men men kissing I got weird fast then
they um okay it's too manly men kissing
come on two guys cuddling they're
cuddling
that's dumb cuddling is okay everyone
likes cuddling
I caught it a lot of the guys I think
that's fine that's it's kind of manly if
you think about it what's manlier than
two people together am i right so now we
have John Cena's face and we take the
Cena face this ace is I like to call it
yes that was high five worthy we crop it
out
so there we go
the real question of this video is top
or bottom I would always go top but
that's just my opinion about things they
already have a you know pretty good
caller matching so that's good now we
all know at this moment that John Cena's
Nick is about six times larger than what
shows in this picture so let's correct
that that looks a lot better already
alright and then we won was his name
Randy we want Randy's face we want him
where you know a little bit of Randy you
know I'm saying all right so there we go
this is great I know kind of want him to
look at John Johnny boy that's the smirk
I want yes and I know what you thinking
this looks like [ __ ] I agree we will fix
it don't worry
I have this picture it's not doing it
for me that that's it yes that's the
picture I've looked for all my life look
at that [ __ ] [ __ ] look at that
my [ __ ] it we're gonna have to go with
its half good one it's not even near as
good as it should have been all right
there we go that's pretty good step3
shadowing all right that looks so good
now I have something I can find
fantasize fat funada bite for that I'm a
fanatic there it is there it is honestly
like this looks [ __ ] awesome I could
frame this [ __ ] it's way better than I
ever expected I want to thank my mom
Larry Stylinson is probably one of the
knows most famous ships on and there in
the universe there's a ton of fan dirty
[ __ ] but they're not like okay they're
pretty graphic um they're not they're
not what I want I want them kissing and
I want it now so we're just gonna do
that yes I know this is super weird and
super creepy but don't worry no one has
to know about this now we can make this
super easy for ourselves
you can't really see his face it didn't
work
all right let's try Harry kissing Larry
doesn't work [ __ ] I thought I had this
in the bag
okay just just close your eyes for a
minute don't look at the pictures I'm
about to look up I'm gonna have to
seriously get rid of my history after
this that is actually adorable man I
made some weird [ __ ] videos not that
there's anything weird about this now it
looks super awkward cuz they're kissing
with their mouths open that's okay we
can solve this
this is [ __ ] hard work man like being
a creepy fan teenager teenager fan like
that's a lot of [ __ ] work
now the problem with this picture is
that their eyes are open so we need to
fix that I mean this face kind of looks
like oh he kissed me but I want more
than just oh he kissed me I want romance
god [ __ ] damn it
that looks awesome I feel like I'm
trying a little too hard on these
there's something wrong with me but at
the same time there's something right
and wrong so there you go
there you have it my sweet children
who else who else is on the list Jesus
Christ
Jesus Christ Jesus Christ Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ Jesus Jesus Jesus Jesus
Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason
Jason oh my god I never realized how
Photoshop a ball killer [ __ ] Clinton
Asst I got it let's do a little break I
gotta do some [ __ ] okay so Hillary
Clinton and Donald Trump no one
suggested this this is just a perfect
personal agenda that I have I stole her
hair cut it looks great look at this
[ __ ] look at this [ __ ] man oh that's
great is it impossible that Hillary is
impossible the ship with anyone that
could be a theory that has not been
proven
[ __ ] you Hillary like it's impossible to
blend our [ __ ] piece I [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay finally it's in a decent place I've
worked really hard for this
I really really oh god it's oh god it's
been so long I don't even want to tell
you how long I've been shooting this
let's shoot some quick color blending
starting to look really really good
let's look at more of your Bros comments
are I'm actually curious arkeo
out of John Cena Randy it's so hot in
here
hashtag erection they look so happy
Larry is real is that Larry yeah what do
you think what do you think I honestly
they look kind of [ __ ] up close but if
you zoom out there all right so just sit
really far away from your computer while
you're fat you're welcome
leave a like be one more offended
whatever I don't want to call this leave
a comment want to call this and I'll see
you breath in the next one
stay awesome rest look fire chiona it
wants to be a platypus I hear they're
really like dangerous like they could
eat off your face or some [ __ ] is that
true this is quality and it's John
you're welcome